STEPHANIE WONG: Hey, everyone.
This is Stephanie Wong,
Cloud Developer Advocate.
We are back with our own
Google fellow Eric Brewer.
Last time, we talked
about his last 10 years
of building infrastructure
at Google and Kubernetes'
influence in the space.
He mentioned how
he is now focusing
on creating processes for more
secure software supply chains.
So Eric, how are
you doing today?
ERIC BREWER: Fantastic.
It's good to see you again.
STEPHANIE WONG: Good
to see you, too.
All right, so let's
dive right into it.
Last time, we were talking about
supply chains for software.
Now, you were talking a little
bit about the risk space
and companies tied to it.
So how is the supply chain risk
assessment happening today?
Why is the risk so large?
ERIC BREWER: Well,
I think there's
a lot we need to do
here as an industry,
and it's beyond the
power of just Google.
In fact, it's really quite a
challenge for the whole planet.
But I would say the first thing
we need to decide is which
projects we want to actually
bet on, because in some sense,
any project you're
betting on for security,
you'd like to make sure that
there are people that care
about that project and are
paying attention to it and will
fix security vulnerabilities
as they arise,
because in practice, 99%
of our vulnerabilities--
literally 99%--
are not in the code that you
write for your application.
They're in this very deep tree
of dependencies, some of which
you may know about, some
which you may not know about.
And so the first thing is what
are those dependencies, which
ones are well-maintained,
which ones are not.
We're starting to present
that kind of information.
But to take it up a
level, it's actually
going to be important
for all industries
to try to understand
what pieces of software
do we want to bet on and why.
And what do we do about the ones
that are not quite up to par
yet?
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
And whether some
companies know it
or whether they have come
to an acceptance of it,
Kubernetes has become the de
facto way to build and deploy
many, many applications today.
Or at least that's the North
Star for many organizations.
And now it has several hundred
software library dependencies,
right?
So what are we at Google
Cloud doing to help
reduce those vulnerabilities?
ERIC BREWER: Well, there's tons.
There's of course, CNCF,
we started as a home
for Kubernetes.
And it's part of the Linux
Foundation, which we also are
big fans of and funders of.
I personally helped create
Open SSF, Open Source Security
Foundation.
That, in my mind,
started in 2019,
although I think it actually
launched in early 2020.
But that foundation is, in
fact, explicitly targeted
at open source security
and the supply chain.
It was created for that purpose.
And fortunately, it was created
before this stuff really
became so visibly bad.
But I could see it
coming, and that's
why we needed to
kind of start early.
The other thing I would say is
that Google has a long history
of committing to open source.
And in our recent response
to the White House,
we committed another $100
million to open source
in the coming years.
And it's important to set that
precedent because the repairs
we need-- there's a
lot of mundane work
to do to make open source as
secure as we need it to be.
And it's not fair to say oh,
volunteers and others, please
work harder.
That's not going to be
the sustainable path.
And in fact, I'm arguing
for federal funding
as well for open
source security.
I kind of feel like we need
to get to a sustainable model
where the ongoing work
of security, which is not
easy stuff, is actually
financially supported,
not just for this year when it's
a crisis, but for the future.
By the way, I think
of it the same way
as you think about other
public infrastructure.
We passed a trillion dollars to
spend on roads and other things
in the US.
Open source is a public
infrastructure also.
And like all public
infrastructures,
it needs maintenance
and support.
And so we have to figure out
how that's going to work.
It's not at all an easy thing.
But I do think that is part
of the path of the future.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yep, and it's
really hard to predict that.
And so I think having the
secure processes in place from
build to deploy is
really key, especially
as we've seen the detrimental
work of adversaries
coming to light.
Now, can you talk a little
bit about our contributions
and the work that we've done
in the open source space?
What are some of the
organizations and the projects
that we've worked on?
ERIC BREWER: I'm a
big fan, as you know,
of kind of raising the level
of attraction over time.
And that gives
developers more leverage.
It allows us to do
more automatically
on both the security side
and the management side.
And Autopilot is a
great example of that.
It's really-- we will manage the
nodes for you and your cluster,
and you don't have to.
And that is a
security improvement,
but it's also, frankly,
just a toil improvement.
Why do the toil of
managing those nodes
if you don't need to?
That's probably not what you're
doing your Kubernetes job.
You probably have
something you'd
like to do, like a business app
or website or a data analysis.
Focus on those things, and
we can manage the nodes.
And that general direction
is the way it's going to go.
We can manage more
things over time,
but they'll be the
things that you
don't want to manage yourself
because it's a hassle.
STEPHANIE WONG: Exactly.
And I do want to dive
a little bit more
into Google Kubernetes
Engine and what
we've been doing over
the last couple of years.
I know that we just had GKE's
sixth birthday, actually.
So why don't we go ahead and
save that for the next episode?
Thank you so much,
once again, Eric.
And to everyone else
watching, stick around
because we are going
to have more soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]